but let's uh let's jump into the first
story and we'll talk about joe biden
being president
and this glorious image from jacobin
magazine
now i'll tell you what i find
particularly fascinating about this is
jacobin is like socialist
like their their dsa many are like
communism
it's they get their name from the french
revolution and they've
put a cover out and it's joe biden as
jesus with the sun
behind his head literally imagery of
jesus and there are people below him
like
looking up and cheering and worshiping
him
and there's angels filming and
interviewing him what
are these people thinking this smacks of
the french revolution the
this was uh what's his name's party um
rob's beer yeah rose pierre's party was
the jacobins
correct me if i'm wrong here but they he
actually became they wanted to get rid
of christianity and he
portrayed himself as a deity and came
down from the mountain and they wanted
to create he wanted to create a new
religion around himself and this is like
a
i don't know if they don't know that or
if this is a sick joke or
or if they really are like maybe that's
why they're doing it
i mean politicians are not supposed to
be worshiped they are
servants they're supposed to be serving
the people and i don't care if it's joe
biden q and on donald trump stop with
this obsession
with putting people above yourself and
putting all their responsibilities and
all your failures and all your hopes
into one person and and take some gosh
darn personal responsibilities for
yourself mother
we're supposed to be saying too early
we're supposed to be doing this we're
supposed to be seeing a chairs going
joseph joseph come here clean up this
mess we've hired you to take care of
these problems
instead they create the problems and
they do whatever they want
they enrich themselves they're not
solving the problems i think we were
talking about this before
the difference between a statesman and
what we currently have with crony
politicians
someone who actually gets an offer who
gets elected and says i'm gonna go in
and focus on solving these problems for
you
and then what we have like one or two
who actually do but when you have a
media ecosystem that is acting like joe
biden is literally jesus
then i don't see how we we actually
solve problems
just to clarify my point joe biden could
do really horrible things
and they don't care but it's funny
because they say the same thing about
you know donald trump i'm kind of in a
place where it's like just
let them have their fun but i don't know
what were you going to say jack
i was just gonna say how are you gonna
criticize jesus
yeah come on man setting him up to be
untouchable and then i'm also reminded
and i'm about ready to do this thing i
hate where i say what about
i'm also reminded about uh this summer
uh when they were tearing down statues
of abraham lincoln
where lincoln's standing there and he's
got his hand out and there's an
uh a slave on his knees breaking out of
his change and standing up a joy
like rapture's face up to up to abraham
lincoln
this this cover with biden as jesus
hovering above
a black family in masks looking up at
him like he's got
that is no different well it is the i
mean i guess technically
the the statue of abraham lincoln was
paid for and built
like organized by former slaves who were
saying thank you
to to lincoln now the leftists today got
that statue removed they actually
approved it was in boston they i can't
believe it they took it
there's one in dc they're trying to take
down the same same statue
they taking it down because they're like
it shows that black people were
at one point slaves and so they want to
erase that they don't want that idea to
exist
so they got rid of it it worked this is
people worshiping
jesus biden who hasn't done anything
what does he what did he do he's
defeated his heart right up against the
wall
he defeated the devil there you go the
evil trump
he may have uh performed what they call
a sexual aggressive act
against tara reid
you know it's it's it's really hard
because i feel like
the things they threw at trump were
preemptive defensive techniques
like you better accuse trump of it
before it comes at us yes
because the democrats are swimming in
the corruption and the swamp
and so they're like let's make sure
everybody thinks trump is corrupt for
like
the emoluments clause for instance joe
biden sending his kid to china on air
force two
a bit different it's like we live in the
empire from star wars and it's like
people just want to just chill out and
just accept it you just want to be a
citizen man you just want to reap the
benefits of the empire
controlling all these planets and
countries or whatever
well so this is the thing i was
mentioning earlier i tweeted
i often wondered what pro-empire
propaganda would look like in the star
wars universe
and it's because we have the entirety of
dc locked down by the national guard
many of them have no idea why they're
there
in order to get in you've got to show
your papers proving you have legitimate
business
why because the storming of the capital
i don't think we need 25
000 troops locking down the entire
capital no as
as adam townsend said on twitter it's
about imprinting history on people's
brains
so that in 20 30 40 50 years they just
look back and like oh things must have
been terrible they had to have 25 000
troops in the capital no one will no one
remember the nuance
i've lived in dc for 30 years i've been
through a number of inaugurations i have
never
once heard of incoming traffic shut down
over the bridges
coming into this city the area that they
blocked off it's like i
this is estimated virginia it's like 20
times the size of anything that had ever
been blocked off before it was just
mind-boggling troops marching
troops marching down the streets there's
a famous meme going around right now
with all the soldiers
uh and and the motorcade going through
and it says we defeated fascism
and and again those images are
extremely visceral for a reason
and we have to ask ourselves why did we
do this why did we
locked down the capital of the united
states
under a military occupation when there
was no protest
i'm hearing a lot of reports of no
protesters at all being seen
anywhere near even the vicinity of
washington dc
protesting uh biden it's the opposite
every single like trump forum was like
don't go
don't go to dc people are saying like
don't do it don't go
but on the mainstream media we heard
non-stop 24 7
breaking news coverage of threat
assessments it's going to get bad it's
going to get ugly people there's it's
going to get bloody and and
dangerous and and what happened it was
such a winning move though because now
all they can say is like
there was a threat we responded to the
threat and we prevented it from
happening
oh yeah because we put the troops there
yeah it's a winning move no matter what
think about the media narrative right
now and how say wikipedia
works they just take whatever op ed and
i'm and i'm not saying
i'm i'm serious they take op-eds
and someone will say there was an
insurrection it's all about framing
so i'm sure if you if you now look at
what the historians are writing they're
going to say there was an attempted
insurrection by white supremacist
terrorists
and then in 50 years that's what they
want everyone you know history is
written by the victors
they want everyone to look back at this
day and say trump's army of white
supremacists stormed the capital
you know planning to kill and kidnap
members and so the troops were deployed
to protect the city to prevent another
insurrection it was a trying time
and they did it and they successfully
were able to fight it back
and it's only going to get worse from
here as we're seeing very
extreme language from individuals like
john brennan
the former cia director that literally
lied under oath about so many different
things whether spying or the steele
dossier
he came out today on the mainstream
media and he said the biden
uh intelligence organizations are moving
in quote
laser-like fashion to uncover
the trump insurgent insurgency and
the people who harbored it including
religious extremists
authoritarians fascists biggest
nativists and even libertarians this was
this was
libertarian he said yes john brennan
said
that biden's intelligence agencies are
moving in laser-like fashion against
libertarians that's a political party
yes yes that's why i just i tweeted the
video out because i couldn't believe it
because i saw people talking about it
but but we have the former
cia director you know the epitome of the
deep state
talking about biden going after
libertarians now because of everything
that happened
the nativist thing was particularly
interesting yes they're making it now
that if you oppose immigration in any
way you're a nist of some sort
and they're making nativists like racist
so i was listening i i
didn't do a 1pm segment today because i
was watching i had to watch the
inauguration out you know and it was
happening at the same time i normally
you know produce and record
and i remember when joe biden mentioned
you know rejecting the hate of nativists
and i was like it's a really interesting
choice of words now people who are like
you're native to the country you get
preferential treatment is wrong it's an
ist and they're going to use it like
racist i would uh so all right
wait native to the country means
american yes right right so if you're
an american yes and believe that that's
important and a good thing
youtube already made the rule a year ago
that if you disparage
non-citizens for being not citizens you
will be banned but most importantly he
went on and he said all of these
things nativists libertarians are a
threat
to democracy and are insidious those are
his
exact inflammatory words that are
extremely reckless
extremely dangerous but also most
importantly extremely
untrue when we talk about libertarians
what are they guilty of not liking the
government being
unsuccessful in politics having cruddy
candidates
uh having some ideas about you know
individual sovereignty and liberty
what are they guilty of what do they do
how do you lump a libertarian in with a
fascist
yeah uh when when everything
again this is another thing we need to
realize here this whole democratic party
was
built as a large hammer hitting nails
so if you're a hammer everything's going
to start looking like nails for you
because that's your single duty
that's the main kind of apparatus that's
how the democratic party gained
power in 2020 let's be honest here they
took down a lot of people and that's how
they were able to
step on them and get a step above
everybody else and
they know that works they know that this
is going to be implemented even more
before this and it doesn't take a genius
to see that the writing is on the wall
that we're going to see an expansion of
this moving forward yeah i think it's
important to point out too that this
process
started in the 60s when the democrats
made a very conscious decision to make
themselves the party of everybody but
the white guy
and to go against the white guys in the
in the late 60s 1968 if you want to
learn more about this
check out matt stoller's book goliath
there's a whole big detailed section
about
the deliberate course of action that the
democrats took and so the the nail
is white dudes and the hammer is what
now
the state and all the non-white dudes
behind them the state and the cia the
fbi
and that's why when when alex was here
he said i am a guerrilla
but love yourself we can all because the
the idea of that book was
you know discussion we were having was
that the the establishment wants you to
live
in the wilderness they want you to live
you know like we used to hundreds of
years ago
and that was a general concept you know
to be completely honest i think people
would do well to get out into the wild i
was gonna say that sounds like a great
good perspective but the idea was like
destroying modern civilization and
technology because we're destructive
it reminds me of the matrix when agent
smith is like you know
humans are not animals they're viruses
you know i'm not gonna do the whole
speech but that's basically what he says
because
animals he say he says build a natural
equilibrium with their environment
whereas humans just
reproduce move around and destroy and
like a virus
that's the same idea from you know my
understanding from that book
and so the idea is to get humans back
into eco state you know
stability with the natural environment
and then that requires
you know the average person to give up
this this way of life so now you
i think what we're seeing especially
with the great reset especially with the
you know the democratic politicians who
have defied their own lockdown orders
the idea is if the rich people are to
maintain their lifestyles
everyone else has to sacrifice with them
so that's what they want that's where
we're headed
all the climate change stuff you know
whatever that's where we'll go
yeah i read ishmael am i supposed to
talk about that right now
it was like it was like 12 years ago
ishmael is the book where the guerrilla
comes from these the gorillas called
ishmael that
alex mentioned and in the book they talk
about takers and leavers
humans have kind of divided into these
tribes of types of people one is the
takers
and and that there's so many takers
right now in the world
that and the levers we've basically
desecrated i think they refer to like
the native americans as leavers in a lot
of ways
protecting the land you know allowing
although they were massacring buffalo
and each other and eating each other i
mean it was pretty vicious
yeah but the idea is to to become
believers and not and to give up our
taking ways and and that i think has a
lot of merit
that's the difference between being a
producer and a consumer i think yeah
yeah
leave mo leave the world a better place
than how you found it the problem is
i don't trust the people who are pushing
this kind of garbage and
now we're getting it tenfold with joe
biden he's going in you know paris
climate agreement that kind of stuff
yeah so for critical race theory even if
you do think it's a good idea you can
really look a scan to the people who are
pushing it
people like i don't know bill gates or
whoever george
bill gates pushing it while at the same
time pic acquiring
every last piece of available farmland
in america and now he's the largest
farm owner in all of the united states i
doubt that wow
mr monsanto the man who like bankrolled
pretty much monsanto with all the stock
purchases
is now in control of the united states
food supply in many ways but now
if you had all that money and you knew
that we were going to print up trillions
of dollars
what is the what is the best thing to
buy in that case
beachfront property because of course
there's climate change
and we have to worry about the rising
ocean tides as bill gates literally
bought oceanfront property
so that tells you everything that we
need to know indeed but raw land and far
and farmland over time have tracked
money supply pretty pretty closely yeah
so that's a good place to be he must
think that there's a lot of inflation
coming oh yeah
yeah yeah i wonder why so here was the
uh
here was the the joke i i mentioned so
we have this from
on twitter from balajis is that he
pronounced his name oblazi
it says he tweeted up and to the right
and it's a picture of the m1 money stock
skyrocketing yep and y'all know how does
that mean money printer go burr
yep you're ready it's going burford no
the money printer is going
i moved away from the mic because i
don't want to blow your eardrums out
yeah it's just that's the sound i'm
making it's just you look at the money
i'm one money stock and it's just
i'm imagining a man screaming at the top
of his lungs
so yep yeah i don't i don't know though
people don't have money right so
some people have mentioned maybe there
wasn't enough money in in circulation
and one of the issues is if people
aren't working at all because of the
coveted lockdown
and they're desperate for any amount of
money then we might actually see
deflation
the wealth will go well i will
concentrate into the hands of the ultra
rich the politicians the elites
and they'll hoard it then by holding on
to it strangling out
the working people a normal person who's
like i need 15 bucks an hour
might finally just break and say give me
10. i don't care i have nothing
and then you can get the same amount of
labor from that person for cheaper
because there's no money for them
not if the democrats get their way you
won't be allowed to hire anybody for
less than 15
an hour all across the country no no but
but think about it what they're doing is
money printing
and that at the same time yeah is
tricking people into thinking they're
getting more when they're not
correct yeah so with the mass printing
of money yep
the people then getting saying oh i'll
get 15 bucks an hour
they're gonna have the same buying power
their lives will not improve
if they if they even can get a job even
if they're valued at 10 or 12
an hour in terms of their utility well
this is the thing the job question is
really really big because when we have
the lower skilled jobs being taken by
immigrants when we have the higher paid
jobs being taken because of these visas
that are going to be reintroduced
what jobs are left none of them and you
would think you know failing wages
huge health care costs then the collapse
collapsing economy would be something
worth noting and talking about
but sadly this is something that hasn't
been mentioned and talked about i mean
we're
we're talking about it but not many
people are which is even more
scary you know what's really crazy about
this too take a look we'll pull back up
the m1 money stock
the real expansion of the money supply
it started in
after the financial crisis so when you
look at this major sharp uptick
look at the angle from 2008 until 2020
before the major spike
and it was still rapidly increasing
right
so i don't know exactly what we can
expect some people have said
m1 my supply doesn't track perfectly
with how the economy functions or
anything like that
but i think you print all this money
then you get joe biden coming out saying
everyone gets a raise to 15 an hour and
then there's enough money in circulation
to balance out that wage increase
while not giving anyone an increase in
buying power yeah the argument is that
you would increase the
gdp to debt ratio which is what happened
after world war ii they printed a ton of
money at world war
ii and then instead of paying back the
debt they just grew
the gdp the gross domestic product so
rapidly that the debt became negligible
and they never ended up paying it back
but that's a that's a healthy use of
debt
if you can borrow money to grow your
business your enterprise or whatever in
such a way
that it dwarfs the size of the debt
that's healthy that's actually a healthy
way and i've seen economists make the
argument that's what's going to happen
now but it doesn't seem like our our gdp
is going to be able to expand that
quickly and that we even have we don't
have the industry that we had in 1945
how would all the lockdowns on all the
factories in china how and asset price
inflation but that's that's why there
are concerns about deflation
if people don't work they don't have
money period
and they'll do anything and they'll get
desperate and you can be like
whereas a normal person might be a
middle manager at a paper company or a
cracker factory
and they make you know 65 000 a year you
take away
that job their savings is drying up and
then you come to and say i'll give you a
buck to shine my shoe they'll be like
thank you sir
and that's how you knock people well
everything is becoming more and more
digital so the likelihood of that
happening
is is less in my opinion but also on the
other hand we are going through a
national coin shortage
yeah so and and then there is a huge
kind of
larger kind of psychological push
to make you know regular fiat notes
something dirty something that transmits
diseases something that we should stay
away from there's this push has been
kind of happening for a while
it's kind of been put in overdrive with
kovid so there's there's a big big push
to
promote a cashless society which is
another big agenda which could
manipulate and control people very
effectively and that's what i've been
saying about bitcoin for a long time
that's why i'm surprised i didn't buy
bitcoin sooner because even when bitcoin
was at like 50 bucks
i was telling people that it was the
perfect currency for the international
elites
who want to be able to track every
exchange of currency around the world
it's a better technology it's trackable
and
you can you can secretly seize control
very very easily it's called the 51
attack and of course the united states
has enough money to do it
i should have bought right then because
that's like kind of obvious
that there was there was so much in the
conspiracy world about a one world
currency
i remember back in like the 2000s people
were talking about the amero do you
remember that luke
yes north america i actually talked to
the mexican president about that and it
was
vicente fox and he was openly pushing
for that
now he's and i interviewed him after he
was president now he's pushing for
drug legalization very interesting guy
but vicente fox was like was like yes we
need a north american union
we need one currency between canada
mexico and the united states of course a
lot of the democrats promoted
this larger idea because they also
promoted the trans-pacific partnership
they also promoted nafta
all of these larger deals which of
course help out multinational
corporations and screw over
the blue collar worker so imagine
imagine if if
mexico was tied in with the united
states and canada economically what kind
of larger exploitation would actually
happen well
by the big multinational powers they
like being able to hire people in
jurisdictions they don't have human
rights laws
i remember when uh i first visited
canada and i was talking to a friend of
mine
i think it's like 14 16 years ago or so
it wasn't like the
wasn't it like for every one us dollar
got seven canadian like the exchange
rate was pretty
wild and so i was talking to a friend of
mine who said that they loved it
because americans would jump the border
and then go party and just spend money
like crazy and it was great they could
pay their rent
very easily it was harder to buy
international products
but their base goods their food their
shelter was very easily covered
by americans who would come and spend
then when everything started to
normalize
that stopped happening and it became
harder for a lot of people in the
service industry to make good money
because they didn't have the wealthy
americans coming and spending all the
cash
and this was part of a conversation
about economic normalization i was
having with a friend
so when it comes to and we've seen
things like this uh in europe
when it comes to trying to make
everybody on the same standard
it's very very difficult to do if it's
done with a finger snap government
proposal and they do it overnight
but that's why bitcoin and
cryptocurrency is so interesting with
this this this constant escalation of
the currency that
that's driving up and up and up it's
getting everyone to be like i
want to do it it's building confidence
in it as a store of value
so people are buying in they're buying
other crypto and it is creating a one
world cashless
society we're on that path through
cryptocurrency
is that a good thing um it could be used
either way
um we've seen a lot of foreign
governments get into the bitcoin game
whether it's china or even more recently
pakistan
deciding that they're going to be
officially mining with
pakistani government money so it could
go in a way where it's used as the kind
of one world currency that's a cashless
grid
total control lack of privacy coin
initiative or it could be used on the
other hand to promote privacy with
privacy coins like monero that are out
there zcash
that do try to hide transactions so
people could still keep their privacy
which i think is important it's a
double-edged sword it's just like the
internet and it all depends on the user
base
what do you do with it what do you
incentivize if you incentivize
you know corporatist globalist coins
that work with the big banks well
obviously those will prosper
if you incentivize privacy coins that
prioritize
your liberty and freedom well of course
those will prosper so right now we're in
the deciding phase of this larger
cryptocurrency revolution
that's unfolding right now that is still
yet to be determined if it's going to be
really good
or really bad for the person look at
social media networks
it was really good for a while and then
started to get really really bad
and then the government realized or i
should say political establishment
realized
oh no we've lost control by giving the
plebs the the ability to communicate
with each other quick take it back
yeah but we wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for that little opening there was
a little opening
right and and that opening has allowed
me to have a job a
independent media organization allowed
you to have a job
allowed other people to have a voice i
don't know uh jack about your personal
kind of history but
there was a moment where everything was
it was like the wild west it was amazing
it was beautiful
anything you saw was organic it was real
it was it was
it was genuine it wasn't corporate it
wasn't fake it wasn't
talking points it wasn't regurgitation
of disney disney bull crap
shoved in your face thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you